but first tonight he is the left-wing
new green deal socialist
most cherished public figure long-time
government doctor
who is often wrong but never in doubt
anthony flip-flop fauci is once again
back in the news after senator rand
paula kentucky he's also a medical
doctor
confronted fauci about his deceptive
testimony
surrounding what we've discussed a lot
it's called gain of function research
and the wuhan institute of virology in
other words the origins of covet 19.
as a reminder the definition of gain of
function
that research often involves
manipulating viruses to make them more
dangerous
more infectious now fauci's nih defines
it itself this is their definition
research projects that could be
reasonably anticipated to enhance
transmissibility via the respiratory
route
in mammals the practice is so risky that
it was temporarily halted
by the u.s government from 2014 to 17
however this kind of highly dangerous
research apparently continued
at the wuhan institute of virology this
as fauci's nih sent millions
of your u.s taxpayer dollars to this
wuhan lab
funneled through a non-profit that's
called eco health alliance
now put simply fauci's nih might have
played a role in developing the deadly
culvert 19
virus that would be something we need to
get to the bottom of
because now according to multiple
outlets including the wall street
journal
a wuhan lab leak is the most likely
cause
of the pandemic that has killed millions
worldwide
but today when asked about this very
real possibility
dr anthony fauci became more indicted
indignant more defensive than ever even
called
senator and dr rand paul uh said he
doesn't know what he's talking about
but i think it was him that didn't know
what he was talking about you decide
dr fauci knowing that it is a crime to
lie to congress
do you wish to retract your statement of
may 11th where you claimed that the nih
never funded gain of function research
in wuhan
senator paul
microphone your microphone senator paul
i have never lied
before the congress and i do not retract
that statement this paper that you were
referring to
was judged by qualified staff up and
down the chain
as not being gain a function
let me finish take an animal virus and
you increase this responsibility to
humans right you're saying that's not
gain a function yeah that is correct and
and senator paul you do not know what
you are talking about
quite frankly and then rand paul read
the nih's own definition of gain of
function
now if all of dr fauci's friends and
colleagues up and down the chain
whatever that means say
it wasn't technically gain of function
research
well then i guess it's settled he's just
totally off the hook
well according to a visibly shaken dr
fauci
yeah senator paul was just propagating
what is called a dangerous lie
you decide if the point
that you are making is that the va the
grant
that was funded as a sub award from eco
health
to wuhan created sars kovi
ii that's where you are getting let me
finish
we don't know wait a minute it didn't
come in the lab but all the evidence is
pointing that it came from the lab
and there will be responsibility for
those who funded the lab
including yourself i totally this
community will allow the witness to read
i totally resent
the lie that you are now propagating
senator
now propagating a dangerous lie really
well here's how senator paul
responded checkmate if you look
at the viruses that were used in the
experiments
that were given in the annual reports
that were published in the literature it
is molecularly
impossible no one's saying those viruses
it is caused
it is molecular those virus caused the
pandemic what we're alleging is
that gain of function research was going
on in that lab and nih funded it that is
get away from it it meets your
definition and you are
obfuscating the truth it does meet his
very definition dr
fauci thought it was cute he's playing
word games in order to escape
any culpability or any responsibility
this
is very serious why on earth
was anthony fauci's nih sending
any money whatsoever to any virology lab
in china who in their right mind would
ever think
that's a good idea and why is fauci
still serving in the white house
forget about the gain of function
research claims for a moment
dr fauci's sloppy guidance during the
pandemic
has been all over the map he has flipped
he has flopped he has flailed the entire
time
march 8 2020 he's trashing
china's draconian lockdowns but on march
15th
he promoted a 14-day national lockdown
in the u.s to slow the spread which
turned into several months
to slow the spread then on january 28
2020 fauci downplayed the asymptomatic
spread of the virus but in august of the
same year
he blamed asymptomatic cases for
community outbreaks
last year he referred to trump rallies
as troublesome
super spreader events he had not a word
to say about last summer's protests and
riots nothing
on mass well first fouchy laughed at the
idea
on 60 minutes told us not to wear any
masks they don't work
then he demanded we all wear one mask
indoors
and also a mask outdoors and two masks
then no mask outdoors and now we may be
wearing masks in perpetuity
we can go on and on and on and on now
here are a few more examples take a look
there is no need to change anything that
you're doing on a day by day basis
right now the risk is still low it was
just bad it is bad now
i think these numbers are so stunning if
you're a healthy
young person that there is no reason
if you want to go on a cruise ship to go
on a cruise it is not a good idea to
travel
period in the united states people
should not be walking around
with masks well if one mask is good
it makes common sense that maybe two
masks are better
if you look at the evolution of the
virus in bats
and what's out there now it is
very very strongly leaning towards this
could not have been
artificially or deliberately manipulated
are you still confident that it
developed naturally
no i'm not convinced about that i think
that we should continue to investigate
what went on in china
he was wrong on cruises he was wrong all
over the place with
bass here there and everywhere and of
course
treatments he was wrong on how the
disease is transmitted
his models his projections were a
disaster and his
nih was sending millions of dollars to
the wuhan
institute of virology before the
pandemic so why on earth is dr fauci
even still employed
and where are the investigations into
his potential malfeasance
and what about those emails that now
tell us a lot more about what he
knew as early as january 31st
of 2020 he was told that it looked like
a specific genome
might have been manipulated in an email
then there were the frantic emails that
went back and forth about uh
do you think there's any chance we
funded this hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else